the following interview is with Amy
she's 23 six months ago she was the
victim of a sexual assault Amy if you'd
like to smoke or move around while we're
talking please feel free to do so I want
you to be comfortable
I'm okay thanks good then why don't you
just start talking and I'll come in with
questions from time to time where would
you like me to start wherever you feel
like
I had to work overtime that night but it
wasn't too late when I finally got off
had you ever thought about the
possibility of being sexually assaulted
I guess I suppose it's something of a
natural fear for most women I also think
that sometimes somewhere we're all
vulnerable to rape you try to be careful
that well you just can't stop living
either you never know when you're going
to make a move that attracts his
attention
I know it's painful having to go back
over this part so we take a break for a
few minutes no I'd rather go on it was
even more terrifying because I had no
warning of what was coming suddenly his
hand was over my mouth and nose my first
instinct was to try and bite but his
pressure was so heavy I I couldn't get
my mouth nothing and every time I try to
struggle you cut my breath off did he
threaten you with a weapon just himself
it was very strong
he hit me several times really hard and
you told me if I kept my mouth shut and
did as he said I wouldn't get hurt
really obviously did not care how much
he hurt me
as long as he got what he wanted so you
did as you were told
at that point it was my only choice I
wasn't even thinking about rape anymore
that was a fact that was happening my
mind had skipped on to the afterwards
part I was so scared he wouldn't keep
his promise I was just sure he would
kill me
I tried to think of something I could
say or do that would stop him but all I
could hearing with his voice yelling
he's gonna give you the whole ticket Amy
you're going all the way I could see it
so clear
thankfully he did nothing more no he
just pulled himself together and left
naturally he warned me that I better not
have any bright ideas about calling the
police right away
but that's all
can you recall how you first felt after
he met you happiness that was my first
reaction no kidding I mean realizing
you're alive when you were so close to
the other well you just can't feel any
other way of course that only lasts for
about 30 seconds then it ends the bad
part you start to remember
control this car five over nine areas
momentarily enacted request permission
for out of service time over the family
car five Roger Roger control
was it the rapists warning that kept you
from calling the police Amy no this part
I can't blame on him I I guess what I
did was to think up my own version of
what would happen if I told him okay Amy
can you tell something about your
previous sexual experiences I mean I
used to having sex with a lot of
different people no okay
now Amy you know having to repeat over
and over again what he did how he did it
did I enjoy it like they were getting
some kind of thrill out of hearing one
more I was also afraid they wouldn't
believe me try to blame me as if I had
really asked for it Amy listen you mean
to tell us that you really didn't want
to have but that Street is one of the
busiest streets in town one scream ah tu
Amy would have brought about a hundred
people right down on top of it are you
used to having such an expensive but you
didn't say anything didn't you didn't
Olivia oh come on Amy tell us the true
pretty romantic back we'll listen you
didn't want to do it
Rob's plants nice to the pong and you
can't just cut it on didn't you come on
Amy answer the question
I couldn't go through it all I cared
about was getting that man's memory off
me I thought if I could just get clean
enough I'd be able to erase the rest of
it
silent scene the least painful thing to
do okay so it happened but I'd come
through it and now I just learn to live
with it
I got rid of everything that reminded me
of him my feelings though weren't quite
as simple to take care of for a while
the days and nights seemed to drift
together beside the emotional pain
there was also an emptiness it was the
same when he was assaulting me the whole
thing had been so impersonal
the real Amy wasn't there he wasn't
wanted or needed only her shell my rape
became my obsession nothing else
mattered I just had to let it wear
itself out and I get started on being a
person again
I did manage to call in to work and make
an excuse for having to stay out I was
sure they knew the real reason from what
I was telling you they didn't of course
but a lot of funny things play around in
your head when you have this kind of
problem you think that somehow everybody
knows about you so you shut them out you
avoid you make yourself safe from their
questions but the times had to come when
you could no longer avoid the rest of
the world yes I had to go back to work
or else there surely would have been
questions by then my outside bruises
were healed and I hope the rest of it
would also go away but it's not that
easy to forget neither is the man who is
responsible I kept thinking about him he
was out there somewhere I had no idea
what he looked like he'd worn a mask
over his face so every man now became
that man excuse me
anyone
no nothing's wrong what would you like I
only wanted to find out about your round
trip excursion to Hawaii
It was as if I couldn't get away from
him he was everywhere
I knew I couldn't handle it alone
anymore
right right um yeah I'm calling about
huh um no I was very nervous about
calling I didn't know what I should say
but Martha the woman who took my call
she didn't need any explanations she
said I know just what you're feeling
I've been through it myself
for the first time since it happened
there was a sense of relief I was
touching with someone else who really
did understand
you hear about these kind of places and
you tuck it up in your memory thinking
well if it should ever happen to me I
know some place I can go not believing
of course that you'll ever need them
and then one day you're ringing their
doorbell you are also one feel town I'm
also a rape victim you don't have to
apologize did you have any trouble
finding a parking place
oh no I took the bus I don't have a car
which is certainly the best solution for
our parking problem hi everybody this is
Amy come on over and sit down next to
Christie says a man Regina Jane Christie
was raped in her college dorm he put her
in the hospital for several weeks
she lost the hearing in her left ear he
beat her with an ashtray Suzanne was
assaulted by her brother's best friend
he tried to strangle her with the
pillowcase luckily her brother came home
Regina has two preschool children she
was raped in a public laundromat with
both of them washing he told her if she
didn't let him do it he would kill the
kids and he meant it
Louise was on her way to her daughter's
house
she was sitting at a bus stop in broad
daylight he threatened her with a
butcher knife he said you're going to do
me a favor grandma he forced her into
the basement of an apartment house and
raped her twice then to show his
contempt he urinated on me before he
left he didn't leave her with much
dignity but Louise was no shrinking
violet when she talked to the police she
told them everything he'd done to her by
the way her rapist was under 16 martha's
happened when she was in high school at
that time rape crisis centers were
almost non-existent now martha spends
much of her time working with other
women who share the same problem on the
phone Martha had asked me if I'd gone to
the police I told her I was too afraid
instead of insisting which she could
sense would only make me more reluctant
to do so she encouraged me to meet some
women who did choose to report their
rapes each of us in the room had
encountered that lone moment with an
angry violent man
Janet described everything she went
through in her particular situation she
was aided by the army CID Special Agents
Janet is a soldier but her other
procedures were much the same as any
woman will experience if she seeks help
right left
hut-hut spit put your lip right there
get up get up there left right left back
left back there oh boy
all right
we help you follow amount you better
call ambulance not forgetting ambulance
we'll take into the hospital ourselves
man can you talk - just listen be
careful hey don't worry about a thing
okay we'll take care of link you to the
hospital all right Janet was on her way
to the PX when she was approached by her
rapist with the offer of a ride after
she got into the car he refused to let
her out and forced her to go with him to
a deserted section of the coast where he
could perform his assault in private and
then have the opportunity to get away
this is Craig Mason at post-hospital
we've did kind of possible rape victim
brought in yes sir dr. Marshall has
already been alerted he's on his way the
rest of the staff is standing by dr.
Marshall need to ask you some questions
about what happened I was on my way to
the PX hello
their first concern was making sure
Janet had no injuries that required
priority and her treatment fortunately
everything was superficial now in
dealing with Janet's rape problem they
proceeded gently we're going to need to
conduct any examination in order to
figure out what's going on okay we also
won't have to ask you some other
questions can you tell me your last
normal period was two weeks ago
are you using anything for contraception
right now we're going to go ahead and
get you set up for an examination and
we'll explain to you exactly what we're
doing to you while we do the examination
okay Janet we're going to need to
collect a sample of your vaginal
secretions we're going to use this
medicine dropper in order to collect
some secretions and look at it under the
microscope to see if there's any
evidence of any sperm okay we also going
to use the comb in order to comb your
cubic hair in order to look for any
extraneous hair they also will take the
q-tip put a q-tip on the inside of your
service and smear sample that material
in this particular growth you will need
for you to get set up for regular pelvic
examination before we do that okay I
know the paperwork there's a lot of it
involved here but right now I just need
your signature on this consent form so
we can have consented procedures
okay thank you lay down we need now if
you like this is part of the examination
Janet mentioned an interesting fact
about the male sperm something I wasn't
aware of sperm can be typed and
classified by its characteristics the
police can use it to eliminate certain
suspects as well as help point the
finger at the guilty party when you stop
to think about it no rapist ever
completely escapes from his victim
he always leaves traces of himself
behind
besides the bad noise if his victim gets
immediate medical attention before
cleaning yourself yes taking a shower
and destroying your clothes are the
wrong things to do
when Janet talked with the CID Special
Agents she found them Frank and what
they had to ask and Tac Toe linear
approach because of their attitude
towards her she was able to give them a
good profile on her since they had solid
leads to work with everyone I muted came
through for you that's the way it should
be rape is not merely one woman's
problem for only women it affects all of
society maybe someday we'll be able to
prevent rape rather than treat its
after-effects but at least we've made a
start it's no longer the dirty subject
nobody talks about did they catch
Janet's rapist yeah they found him
because of Janet's cooperation and her
willingness to testify he was stopped
before he could do it again they gave
him time to think about what he'd done
most of their rapists have been
apprehended and punished at least they
had the satisfaction of knowing that
their rapist would not be victimizing
other innocent persons it was the right
thing to do
Martha went with me to the hospital of
course all the evidence that could have
helped was gone but I did find out that
I wasn't infected or pregnant Beverly
and the police they weren't it all like
the bad guys in my fantasy I couldn't
give them much to go on but at least now
they know about knowing he's still out
there
I keep looking at strange men wondering
if they are the one
someday welcome back here
but I'm just a little nervous yet a
little engine I need some distance for a
while at least the city I'm going to
they have a place where girls like me
can get together and share their
feelings so already I know I've got some
friends I've told the police where I'll
be in case they happen to get looking
you never know
think that any last thoughts you'd like
to leave us with egg yes the main reason
I wanted to be part of your interviews
with rape victims was distress to every
woman who hears this tape please don't
be afraid to get help if you are
assaulted it's an obligation that goes
beyond yourself you can prevent him from
causing another woman's pain
perhaps it was some other woman silence
that let him find me and now I've given
you the chance to do it again he's
walking free and easy and keys
I think a lot about his next victim I
wish I knew some way to warn her
I wonder if she'll be as lucky as I was
will he keep his promise to her when it
happens to her will she come through the
experience will she be able to tell
about it
and will she how many women will he have
to hurt before that one speaks out
against him
that's me
whoever you are I'm sorry
amy has left town since this interview
was recorded
unfortunately her rapist is still with
us
Paulo city Zebulon that intersection the
Pinewood amoral Rose rape victim female
March 28 years old
you
you